c'est une transformation majeure la
Société de l'assurance automobile du
Québec amorce un virage numérique
plusieurs services et documents seront
bientôt offerts en ligne grâce au
portail saclic par exemple on pourra
demander d'annuler ou remplacer un
permis de conduire transférer une
propriété lors de la vente d'un véhicule
obtenir son dossier de conduite ou
encore faire une auto-décration médicale
de lave même du PDG de la SAAQ il est
éteint oui c'est un prix du temps mais
c'est le temps qu'il faut prendre pour
faire bien les choses l'objectif est de
donner plus d'autonomie aux clients et
surtout de limiter les déplacements dans
les succursales
les points de service vont demeurer
ouvert mais les employés ils seront
moins nombreux moi je suis quelqu'un qui
est fournissemment habile avec internet
fait que moi ça me rend service de venir
ici ceux qui sont habitués qui sont à
l'aise avec ça parfait mais pour ceux
qui sont moins à l'aise en ce moment à
l'eau qui garde quand même le service
cette petite révolution demandera un
grand déménagement 10 milliards de
données devront être converties la SAQ
prévoit donc une période de transition
de 3 semaines du 26 janvier au 16
février seuls quelques services
essentiels comme le remplacement d'un
permis perdu ou volé seront maintenus
des services qu'on va continuer à offrir
pendant cette période là on va continuer
à les offrir mais en mode manuel
donc sans technologie à partir du 20
février le service en ligne sera
accessible mais en période de rodage on
demande aux clients d'être patient
pendant cette période-là ça va arriver
juste une fois cette transition
numérique a coûté 458 millions de
dollars à la société d'État qui espère
que ce nouveau service en ligne va aussi
l'aider à pallier la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ici Camille Carpentier
Radio-Canada Québec